[Musique]
la vieille dame du pont du quai
l'académie française a des comptes à
régler avec les académiciens pétain
d'abord
et puis abel bonnard d'amp et invite un
ministre
et puis à des normands qui nous enseigne
à la collaboration
et puis charles maurras et puis
peut-être quelques autres pour morath la
justice âge a lyon on a vu maurras
assisté de morize peugeot comme du
nombre endormi base et devant la cour
accusés de crimes contre la patrie on
l'a vu hier côté menacé trépigner opposé
le fatah de ses attractions de ces
sophisme et de ses diatribes rageuse il
a sauvé sa tête mais la patrie la
condamner
né dans ces magnifiques martigues où il
revenait chaque année que plus morale
d'une intelligence et d'une intelligence
des voiliers un talent mais en allant
perverti
[Musique]
il se range à en signant plusieurs
oeuvres pause mais brillante au nombre
de ceux acquis l'académie réservé à
votre oeil sous la coupole mais au-delà
de cet homme qui nous suivront avec ses
idées et non avec les hommes ce sont ces
idées que la nation a jugé ces oeuvres
corruptrice de l'actif été chaque jour
depuis 35 ans c'est cette doctrine mère
de tous les fascismes dont mousseau
ligny se réclamait et qui trouvent là
une part de la jeunesse française
aussi des rangs des marines il enseigne
et accueillir entre une motion anciens
vont vouloir nous la ferons son sol
forêt de vitrines basé sur la théorie
des pauses l'élite et le mépris du
peuple elle était catholique d'abord
mais un jour du ciel de saint pierre le
pape l'a condamné formellement elle
était monarchiste d'abord mais un jour
le descendant des rois de france
désavoué morale et l'action française
elle était nationaliste d'abord mais le
nationalisme maurrassien on arrivait à
prêcher la déportation il faut donner à
l'allemagne la main d'oeuvre dont elle a
besoin et que les morasses on arrivait à
dénoncer les patriotes il faut traiter
les communistes prisonniers comme des
otages et les exécuter sans tarder et
écrivain mort à la prison perpétuelle
telle est la condamnation de l'homme qui
exigeait de terre et l'académie rejette
cet homme qui n'a pas été l'agent de
l'ennemi mais l'ennemi même cet homme
qui a jonglé avec des idées mais n'a
jamais raisonné avec la faire et le
temps un fauteuil et 10 de la coupole
[Musique]